hello everyone welcome back to the 1914
tournament of some Peterburg we're back
at the Capablanca saga and we are at the
second game ever played between hostile
kappa blanka and the world chess
champion Emanuel Lasker now we should
remember that this is now we're entering
the second part of the tournament these
five players capablanca Oscar tarush
elation and Marshall have you know
qualified for the second leg of the
tournament and now five of them I will
play a double round-robin everyone
against everyone with both white and
black pieces so it's gonna be it's gonna
be beautiful
I do hope you're ready for that and yeah
without further ado capablanca now gets
a second crack at the world champion and
since you'll enjoyed that nice epic
music for the first game ever between
capablanca Oscar I have included the
first thing you will see in the
description below is a link to some more
epic music so feel free to get in the
mood for this
excellent game or you know just pick any
you like so I will give you a couple of
seconds to decide on that for those of
you who have listened and came back
congratulations you are an excellent
listener of epic music and photos we
just want to enjoy the show couple uncle
goes for efore as usual we have E 5 by
Oscar night of three nights the c6
Bishop to b5 Duru Lopez we have a 6 by
Oscar the Murphy's defense Bishop to a 4
and now Knight to f6
we have castles by Capablanca and now
Knight captures any for this is a
well-known line that has been played
then and it is still played today I will
also include I will also mention one
game that was played this year in this
exact same line
d4 by Capablanca b5 now pushing the
bishop back but should be three and not
B 5 will D captures on e5 Bishop to e6
and not Knight B to d2
attacking the knight Knight to c5 and
here c3 and here you could capture the
bishop and the window bishop repair but
it's it's been known then and it's known
now that this is not oh there's
something black like to get something
out of this
Alaska went for d4 and it's interesting
this is the exact the exact same
position I mean it was played in 1940
in this game and it was played also this
year in 2019 kramnik had the white
pieces in the 2019 Tata Steel tournament
against momma Dee Arif and Kramnik
played Bishop captures a nice X here and
that game ended ended in a draw
and it's interesting Bishop captures on
e6 is a slight favorite by the engine
then the move Capablanca played couple
Lanka played CCAP force on d4 and it's
the second best option by the engine so
ok makes sense that you know today
players would go for the absolute best
line but capablanca doesn't need an
engine to you know play play an
excellent game we have night chapters on
d4 Knight captures on d4 Queen captures
on d4 now and Bishop captures on e6 with
Knight captures any sex by Lasker and
now Queen to f3 a nice developing move
that also pressures the rook there and
here rook to d8 preparing Queen to d5 y
square wants to exchange Queens also
gets the rock out out of harm's way we
have a four by Capablanca as b5 is a
very nice target and here there is a
disposition has been reached in modern
chess I think around six times and the
five of the times Bishop to b4 was
played as Bishop to b4 is the absolute
engines favorite but in those days of
course Alaska had no access to engines
Velasco played a nice human move Queen
d5 Alaska offers a queen trade and he
challenges kappa blanka to an endgame we
have Queen captures Capablanca accepts
we have rook at force on d5 attacking
the e5 pawn and now you could go for a
night of 3 to defend the pawn but
capablanca has a different plan he he
decides to go for an active idea a
capture Sun b5 with a cap for Sun be 5
and not rook to e8
check so you could defend against this
check in a few ways if you go something
like King d7
this is possible but then you're gonna
have problems developing your bishop as
the rook on h8 would be hanging so here
you would have to go for g6 Bishop g7
maybe trade rooks and it's Alaska
decides to go about it differently after
Luke 2:8
we have Knights to d8 now now the bishop
is free to develop if f4 is pushed to
defend e5 pawn then Bishop c5 check the
bishop will be the
to the temple so here we have night
Stewie for backup of Monica deciding for
a pawn sacrifice but as you'll see it's
only a temporary pawn sacrifice and it
gives kappa blanka huge initiative we
have rook captures on e5 by Lasker and
now rook to d1 a very nice idea rook
captures on e4 loses the game
immediately for Alaska for example if
Roe captures then rook D captures King
g7 and now rook e8 check will win win
the game rook captures on e4 white black
white is up a whole rook
so after rook to d1 last pair went for
Bishop to e7 defending the knight and
now comes f3 my capablanca defending the
knight here and here
rook to f5 couple monk wants to play
Bishop to f4 to harass the rook can also
attack the c7 pawn so look to f5 first
we looked the c8 kappa blanka now
attacks the c7 pawn and this is why I
said it was only a temporary pawn
sacrifice there's no good way to defend
this pawn you can block with the bishop
the knight would simply capture it and
also if you push C five years the bishop
and rook now defended upon but now do
you see how white wins material and the
game here it's pretty pretty
straightforward rook captures here the
ship has to capture and now the d6 score
is no longer guarded 96 check picks up
the rook moves just check and again
white white is just a material and
winning so after Luke the c8 Alaska
decides okay I've you know been hanging
on to that pawn for as much as possible
but now we need back the activity rook
captures on c7 by capablanca and now
Bishop to b4 we have Bishop to e3 by
Capablanca and not the knight really
doesn't have all that many squares to be
developed through so nice to e6 Lasker
who brings back the Knights into the
game attacks couple markers rook and now
also allies Chris Rock is ready to join
join the game I would have rook C to d7
the material and the board is completely
equal even the bishops are of the same
color but what capablanca has going for
him is that he controls the D file he
already has double looks here so he does
have a bit more control over the board
rook to c8 Alaska develops the rook on
the other open file on the board there's
also the a file but Alaska has the idea
of planet penetrating the position here
with rook to c2
we have rook 1 to d5 attacking the rook
but also pressuring the undefended b5
pawn Laskaris accepts we have rook
captures rook captures and now if you
play rugby 8 to defend it's just a
passive position where you would be
stuck defending the pawn not something
you won't do
so Lasker goes for the for the active
idea rook to c2 offering a couple
Blancas if he wants to capture the b5
phones and Lasker can capture the b2
point for example if captures rook
captures here and then it's the material
is exactly the same I mean there's no
threat of winning some material because
Bishop e3 will offer a trade of rooks so
here it would be just a drone in kappa
blanka is not interested in a draw
against the world champion I mean why
would he
after all he is kappa blanka so after
rook to c2 he plays b3 and here the idea
is similar but a bit different as you'll
see Alaska goes for rook to be you know
it seems like it's the same but it's not
now kappa blanka capture son b5 we have
rook captures on b3 but now it's
different
kappa blanka plays Bishop to d2 were
threatening to win material here and
there's no good way to defend here cos
square has to give up two pieces for the
rook there's no Bishop e3 because the
rook is no longer and b2 the rookies on
b3 so here
Alaska goes for it he plays Bishop to c5
we have rook captures on c5 we have
Knight captures on c5 and now Knight
picks up the knight back and now
Capablanca has a knight and a bishop
against the rook but usually this will
give you winning chances and it's most
of the times it will be easy to play but
this time it's not easy to play because
all of the pawns are on the same stuff
the side of the board three against
three with the Kings there so it's hard
to it will be hard to outmaneuver the
rook and this game is often used as an
example about will mention about what
later we have rook to be two attacking
the bishop a couple Blanca moves back
bushel three three now rook to e2
attacking the bishop again preventing
the King from entering the game bishop
f2 now I will f6 by Alaska and now into
f1 ruku goes back to a 2 doesn't allow
the king to enter the game
we have g4 now King to f7 and now Knight
to e4 and now it's a the idea is simple
but it's it's hard to accomplish it you
want to improve your position as much as
possible you want to push your pawns as
for as far as possible block 8 the
position get your king to be as active
as possible if if possible and somehow
somehow win some material at least one
of the points and then you can look for
something more as of course you are not
expecting the world champion to blunder
anything we have h6 by Lasker and now
Kings you do bringing the king into the
game rook to a3
we have f4 now grabbing more space and
now rook to b3 Lasker just has to wait
and see what couple uncle will do Oscar
does not have an active plan here nice
the g3 we have rook to a3 back and not
Knights to f1 Luke the d3 and now comes
Knights to e3
it's okay the night and there should now
create a wall against the rope maybe the
king can now enter the game I will rock
the c3 and now King to f3 is played
Knight to f5 also seems like an
excellent move for kappa blanka as you
prevent any future g6 ideas dh6 pawn is
hanging the king cannot really move
anywhere from the g7 pawn as you would
threaten to capture and the knight is
protected there so it's an excellent
outpost but it's not clear how white
would make progress here with the night
and f5 you can't really you could go
it's very unclear how you would get your
King into the game although it's a nice
move Capablanca goes about it
differently after Luke c3 King to f3 we
have looked back to a 3 and now f5 now
kappa blanka blocks the position this
way
rook back to a tube we have Knight to d5
now Luke the b2 and not nice to f4 we
have looked to a 2 now comes h4 we have
looked to a5 and now comes Bishop to b4
so the bishop will now create a wall
along the 4th Frank so maybe the King
can also enter the game rook to a3 check
and now you can't go King e4 because
room g3 just wins the pawn so Capablanca
has to bring the show back Bishop to e3
and now comes rope 285
night the h5 backup a Blanca we have
rook to e4
now again pressuring the g4 pawn knights
the g3 King to g8 and now comes Knight
back to e4 we have King to f7
Alaska just waits to see what Capablanca
active plan will be rush up to d2 and
now rook to a-1 again with ideas if King
moves then rubgy 1 will go after the g4
pawn bishop the c3 now the night and the
night now protects the bishop and now
the king is protected from any checks
along the 3rd ranked rook to f1 check we
have nice 2 f2 if you move the King
again Ruby g1 would just attack the g4
pawn rook c1 attacks the Bishop Bishop
d4 we have rook to e1 and now Knight to
e4 rook to f1 check we have Bishop to
have to do now now capablanca defends
differently and now again maybe the King
can enter the game look to a 1 and now
King to f4 we've grouped to a for
pinning the night we have Bishop to c5
and now comes Luke to c4 are pressuring
the bishop we have King to f3 rook the
c1 and now comes Bishop back to f2 rook
to e1 by Lasker King back to f4 rook to
a4 by Alaska and now King to f3 just
repeating the position a few times and
now rook to a3 check bush after e3 kappa
blanka blocks check rook to a5 and now
comes Knight to c5 and now ok definitely
capablanca has made some progress maybe
now the king can definitely enter the
game
rook to a-1 again now it's a bit
different because if you go with the
king in the center of the board the
bishop is controlling g1 so you cannot
attack at the g4 phone from g1 but there
are other squares available of course
for last courts look 96 we have rook to
e3 pinning the bishop now the in in some
crazy scenario where Capablanca could
escape checks from from the rook an
ideal maneuver would be bishop here to
to dare to capture this pawn as the
knight protected but as the g4 point is
really weak and the King has to avoid
checks this is not not a possible plan
we have kink the e for now Capablanca
manages to get
King in the position rook to e4 check
bishop to d4 and now look the b4 there's
really not much for white to do here as
the bishop is pinned rook pink the d3
now capablanca tries to enter the
position all the way from the Queen side
look the b3 check and now again you
can't go here because of roof to g3 so
King back to e4 now room g3 again King
returns to a for Kings the room back and
so on so rook there before Lasker again
pins the bishop and we have kink to d5
now rook to b1 and now comes well you
could play h5 which doesn't make sense
but then it's and then we go into Luke
b5 check Bishop c5 and rook to b8 and
here you don't really have a way of
pushing for any advantage here you could
go king d6 rugby 3 now comes King to d7
roof to g3 you go after the pawn and now
we go into this line Bishop to f8 you
attack the g7 pawn rook captures on g4
Bishop captures on g7 and pound of
course you cannot capture here you can't
give up the rook for two pieces because
this endgame would just be winning for
white king has to move and then you just
capture and win the game but you don't
have to capture it after Bishop captures
you could go rook h4 go after they spawn
and then after Bishop captures rook
captures 98 check King g8 you wouldn't
just go rushing back to e3 now after
disappoint is lost you would have this
bishop and night against the look and
the pawn just not possible and anymore
for white so h5 although it improves the
position it's it only improves to to a
draw so couple uncle goes for g5 we have
H captures H captures GF captures and g5
and not Knight captures and g5 with
check there's a wall created against the
black king so Lasker king Alaska's King
has to go back King to g8 and now comes
Knight to e6
the g7 point is under attack and if
Capablanca wins this pawn for example if
Knight captures and Knight can move back
then the DF point is just winning so
Lasker has to figure out some way to
defend against this and he does he finds
rook to d1 now the idea is that if we
capture with the night root cap
Chandi for we'll draw the game after
King captures sorry after the roof is
captured King captures night now comes
King to e5 King to f7 now comes f6 and
after King f8 here black creates the
opposition and of course it's a draw
so after look to d1 a couple uncle
cannot afford this he plays King efore
gets the King out of the way now perhaps
the Bishop captures and g7 is an idea
but Lasker figures out a way around it
king f7 and now if Bishop captures on f7
you get rook to e1 check King to d5 and
not look to f1 there's no way to defend
the DF born the night has to stay where
it is if the knight moves then the
bishop is lost
so after king e5 you defend rookie one
checking moves back in b6 again Rock f1
there's no way to defend it would just
be a draw as Lasker would be able to
just go rook e1 rook f1 so after King F
7 we have Knight to g5 check by kappa
blanka King g8 and now king e5 there was
no way to immediately win the g7 pawn
Saka Blanca has to keep improving the
position rook e1 check with we have King
to f4 rook to f1 check King g4 we have
rook to d1 now attacking the bishop
Knight f3 defending Luke to f1 and now
Bishop to e5 King to f7 with King to f4
and now King back to g8 Alaska again
just wait to see what happens kingi 4 we
have rook to d1 not allowing the king to
enter the game via the D file Knight to
g5 and now rook back to e1 with Czech
King D 5 but now just wrote d1 check
King e6 and rook to e1 pinning the
bishop once again and as long as Lasker
keeps doing this there's no ever aderson
no way ever to approach the this Jeep on
wood the king so you can win it with one
piece you have to attack it with both
night and Bishop to win it and of course
if you just exchange the pawn then it's
just a draw so Knight h3 Capablanca
again tries a different path
rook the be one we have Knight to f4 and
now rook to be six checks
King to e7 we have looked the b5 now
attacking the bishop Knight to g6
defending and now look back to b6
there
are some ideas where kappa blanka if
this rook who really wanders somewhere
somewhere you know wrong I can't even
figure out how that would happen maybe
maybe a couple Blanca could sacrifice
the bishop and then go f6 f7 and f8 but
all of these moves would have to be made
with tempo
you know either checking the king but
it's I don't see that happening so rush
up to d6 blocking the sixth-ranked we
have looked racex
again the bishop is just pinned this is
all oscar has to do if you if you
continue attacking or pinning pieces
then there is no way both night and both
Bishop and Knight will be able to attack
the g7 pawn king is sex with rook to b6
and now comes Knight to e7 check King h7
and now Knight to c8 attacking the rook
rook to a6 and now comes Knight back to
e7 rook to b6 and now comes nice the d5
attacking the rook from here Rema
nuvaring rook to a six-night the c3 we
have King to g8 velasca nice to see for
my Capablanca and here Lasker played
rook to b6 this has moved 100 and it was
in this position that josé raúl
capablanca
and the World Chess Champion him at last
agreed to a draw now it's a really
really an impressive endgame a lot of
strong players throughout the history
have analyzed this game everyone had a
different opinion than someone's opinion
was that this guy's opinion that made an
analysis before me was wrong then
engines have made analysis about this
this entire endgame but I don't think
that this day you know that conclusion
has been reached
whether Capablanca could have won this
game or not
may-maybe it they've done it I don't
know I have searched for it but I was
unable to find any such evidence so if
you have any evidence was it was it
possible for a couple bunker to play
this differently or to a win because
some players have written in books that
Capablanca could help on it but then
other others are refuted it with engine
lines and you know it's just just crazy
but this game I mentioned that we are
going to mention it it's it's been used
by many players as an endgame like a
tutorial how to how to defend ours
endgame with rook against the bishop and
Knight and Alaska just did
tastic job on it Sam if any of you do
have some more information about this
game do share in the comments I will
either you know give it up give it a
heart or pin it so everyone can see
or if you have access to some sort of a
supercomputer or something you know just
drop the PG and in and let us know if if
these great players missed something so
you know I don't think will benefit from
it but you know it's it's just nice to
know ya second game ever between host
row Capablanca Emmanuel Lasker again a
couple on cope with a better position
pushing for a win but Alaska able to
hold to a draw just the amazing guy this
Emmanuel Alaska Sam I do hope you
enjoyed this game and that you're
enjoying my coverage of the capablanca
saga so far I would like to thank Evan
Holford can Stefan mods nested Nielson
Nazari a brain shook and Jeremy Hobart
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon planning a fun video
for later today I'm sure it will enjoy
it and then we're just continuing the
Capablanca saga as it's just just a
wonderful saga to you know to explore so
yeah I think y'all and I will see you
soon as usual